pero después del informativo llega la
economía aquí a directo a América
edición nocturna Para ello Contamos con
nuestra compañera Daniela Blandón
bienvenida Dani Muchas gracias Rodri
vamos a empezar hablando de Estados
Unidos porque hubo pocas sorpresas en
las en las decisiones que tomó hoy la
reserva Federal de qué se trata Mire le
voy a contar una cosa a Rodrigo el
mercado casi siempre adivina lo que va a
hacer el Banco Central de Estados Unidos
en cada reunión de política monetaria
esta vez también adivinaron subió dos
tasas de interés en 25 puntos básicos
pero la clave Nunca es la decisión en sí
Si no los anuncios que se hagan en la
rueda de prensa posterior para poder
predecir Cuáles son los siguientes pasos
que va a dar y eso fue lo que dijeron
hoy
no se tomó una decisión sobre una pausa
habrán notado Que en la declaración de
marzo teníamos una oración que decía el
comité anticipa que puede ser apropiado
un endurecimiento adicional de la
política esa oración ya no está la
declaración la eliminamos ellos cuidan
sus palabras pero para la Fed quiere
decir que ya la posibilidad de seguir
subiendo tipos no está cerrada del todo
pero para el mercado quiere decir que
ese cambio de lenguaje podría ser el O
podría significar el último aumento en
las tasas de interés en este escenario
ganan quienes tienen ahorros en
productos bancarios como créditos a
término fijo Porque pueden ganar más
intereses pero quienes pierden son los
que tienen créditos con tasas variables
porque tienen que pagar más por sus
créditos la verdad que Estados Unidos
tanto ayer como hoy nos está dando casi
económicas Daniela más adelante iremos
en directo a también hasta Washington
para ampliar este tema venimos ahora a
Colombia porque el gobierno decretó el
más fuerte aumento en los precios de la
gasolina en años Pues todo tiene un
trasfondo Y es que los subsidios a la
gasolina han ido acumulando un déficit
en las arcas oficiales de más de 7.600
millones de dólares en los últimos años
debido a que se estima que en el país el
costo del balón está por de de los
precios internacionales para reducirlo
el gobierno de Gustavo Petro ha venido
realizando ajustes agresivos en los
últimos meses este mes el más alto del
que se tenga noticia en muchos años o
por lo menos desde que yo cubro este
tema 600 pesos colombianos por galón
nunca lo había visto hoy un galón cuesta
en pesos lo equivalente a 2,5 dólares a
precios de dólar de hoy es decir que en
menos de un año se ha incrementado en
casi una tercera parte el nuevo ministro
de hacienda Ricardo Bonilla incluso ha
anunciado que el precio debería llegar a
los 16 mil pesos colombianos unos 3,4
dólares al cambio actual ahora el temor
es que esos ajustes generen mayor
inflación
muy grande desde luego vamos con una
noticia que me sorprende un poco y es
que una empresa israelí imprimió un
filete de pescado así como lo está
diciendo usted mire Este es un nuevo
desarrollo en una industria incipiente
que planea llevar a la mesa carne
procesada en laboratorios a partir
las células una tecnología que solamente
está aprobada para el consumo en
Singapur la empresa stakeholder a Foods
se asoció con una empresa de este país
de Singapur y dice que imprimió en 3D el
primer filete de pescado listo para
cocinar lo que hacen es extraer las
células de mero y convertirlas en
músculo en grasa después de después la
fabrican con impresoras especiales para
imitar las propiedades del pescado
capturado en el mar estas dos compañías
esperan llevar sus primeros productos al
mercado en 2024 la carne de res y del
pollo cultivados en laboratorio han
estado llamando mucho la atención como
una manera de eludir El costo Ambiental
de la agricultura y también de abortar
las preocupaciones sobre el bienestar
animal pero pocas empresas han
incursionado en los productos de mar
porque hay menos estudios sobre este
tema pues muy interesante la verdad
quizás en el futuro veamos más empresas
como esta la verdad Daniela vamos ahora
hasta Rusia con una noticia que todavía
me sorprende es que tinder ha cerrado
ahí ha cerrado sí la propietaria de la
aplicación de citas es una de las pocas
compañías occidentales que Todavía
siguen en Rusia más de un año después de
que la invasión de Ucrania desatara un
Éxodo masivo que dio paso a
que empresas chinas por ejemplo
ampliarán su presencia en la nación esta
firma con sede en Texas reveló que ya
desactivó las opciones de pago para los
usuarios rusos en abril de 2022 muchos
estaban preguntando qué pasó aquí con mi
aplicación y abandonar a Rusia
definitivamente antes del 30 de junio de
este año argumentando que está
comprometida con la protección de los
Derechos Humanos este cierre también se
da en medio de un esfuerzo del kremlin
de apuntalar su sector de tecnología y
también de fortalecer las leyes para
regular la industria tecnológica
probablemente veamos un tinder con
nombre ruso igual anteriormente además
hay otras empresas de aplicaciones
1.320 millones de dólares la aerolínea
de bajo costo India Go First dice que
este es el monto de los ingresos que ha
dejado de recibir y los gastos
adicionales que ha tenido que incurrir
que la obligan a declararse en
bancarrota la quinta aerolínea más
grande de esta nación culpó a los
motores que le provee la compañía
aeroespacial estadounidense prat and
Whitney pues asegura que son defectuosos
y que la han obligado a inmovilizar casi
la mitad de su flota de medio centenar
de aviones todos los vuelos programados
Entre hoy y el viernes fueron cancelados
Daniela aquí cerramos este repaso
económico Muchas gracias por estar nos
vemos mañana